thank you for being here our heart is
broken Lisa we all love you Priscilla
Presley is speaking out following the
death of her daughter Lisa Marie Presley
on Monday Priscilla shared her gratitude
to all those who have offered their love
and support on Twitter writing thank you
all for your condolences you have
touched me with your words it has been a
very difficult time but just knowing
your love is out there makes a
difference
sweet message comes just one day after
Priscilla spoke at Lisa Marie's memorial
service on Sunday at Graceland Priscilla
spoke to the crowd who gathered at the
Presley family mansion in Memphis to pay
their respects reading a message from
one of her granddaughters who reflected
on their late mom in 1968 she entered
our world born tired fragile yet strong
she was delicate but was filled with
life
she always knew she wouldn't be here too
long now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
in addition to Lisa Marie's fans and
family friends were in attendance to
honor the singer-songwriter as well
Billy Corgan Alanis Morissette and Axel
Rose were among the artists to perform
at the service
[Music]
I wanted to do right by her and the
family and and the fans so it meant a
lot the Blackwood Brothers quartet took
the stage as well singing two songs How
Great Thou Art and sweet sweet Spirit
per the family's request
there's a sweet
sweet spirit
in this place
it was an honor for us to be there and
to be able to sing Elvis How Great Thou
Art was one of the the songs that that
he done just about every show and it was
always something that was very special
Lisa Marie was laid to rest at Graceland
alongside her son Benjamin Keough and
her father Elvis Presley after going
into full Cardiac Arrest at her home in
the LA area on January 12th she had many
thoughts about what her funeral would be
like there was no question she wanted to
be buried at Graceland next to her son
and the one thing she said is just don't
make it sad she wanted to be a
celebration and that's what's going to
be following her sudden death Lisa
Marie's friend Winona Judd opened up to
E.T sharing an important reminder
love the ones you're with love the ones
you're with that and forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness that's on my
list every single day
[Music]